food delivery
it's the thing that saves millennials
from starvation
by my calculations americans order over
20 million restaurant deliveries
every single day over half of these
deliveries are actually within walking
distance
but 9 out of 10 are delivered in
cars so basically
we are moving a two pound burrito in a
two-ton car
20 million times a day the energy to
bring you that burrito
is actually bringing you a two ton metal
cage with heated seats
let's be honest we are addicted to our
cars
did you know that in america for every
car
there are four parking spots in some
downtowns
over half of the real estate is for cars
we have designed our cities around our
cars
because we drive whether we're going 2
miles or 200 miles
solo or with our whole family be getting
to the same suv
to go buy coffee or a coffee table
if we could free up some of these
streets and parking lots we could build
more housing more
social spaces more parks but to do that
first we need to rethink how we are
using cars today
in the city of the future if you want to
go five blocks
you summon a bike or a scooter if you're
in a rush
a passenger run would pick you up and if
you need food
no need to have someone drive over the
food will make its way to you
let's go back to those 20 million a day
restaurant deliveries
if we could get these deliveries off the
road we could reduce the need for as
many as one and a half
million cars just in the us that's
twice the size of san francisco now
think of the impact this could have on
cities like
delhi or my best city of tehran
where car pollution is killing thousands
of people every year
so how do we get some of these
deliveries
off the road well that's a question
that my team and i have been obsessed
with over the last three years
and the solution is actually one of the
building blocks
of the city of the future we've been
creating
small self-driving robots that navigate
quiet alleys and sidewalk on a walking
pace
and have a secured cargo to deliver you
food and supplies
now before i tell you more about the
robots
let's do a quick thought experiment in
your mind
picture a city with thousands of robots
is it this one this hollywood dystopia
is what a lot of people expect but our
job
is to create a friendly future that's
designed for people
so instead of making aliens
we set out to create robots that are
familiar
robots that would belong in our
communities
but we also wanted a little surprise
something
unexpectedly delightful think about it
you're walking down the street
and you see your very first robot that's
a moment
when you're gonna decide if this is a
future you love
or fear and with a lot of people having
this
dystopian ideas we need to open their
minds
we want to surprise and delight them so
that we can win them over
on first impression this is what we came
up with it's familiar
but it's also surprising it's just a
shopping cart
but it also looks like the crossbred
volley with minions
if you live in san francisco or los
angeles chances are
one of these has already delivered your
food as soon as we put robots out on the
street
we learned some really interesting
problems like how should robots
cross the road or how should robots
interact with people
with visual or mobility impairments
we quickly realized that we need to
teach our robots
how to communicate with people
people on the sidewalk come from every
walk of life
so we needed to create a new language
kind of a universal language so people
and robots
can understand each other right off the
bat because
no one's going to be reading user
manuals
we started with eyes because eyes are
universal
they can show where the robot is going
or if it's confused
plus eyes make robots more human
we also use sounds for example
we created this running sound with
frequent gaps
so that people with visual impairments
could locate their robots
using the doppler effect but it turned
out
these were not enough at intersections
cars would cut in front of our robots
drivers were getting confused sometimes
because robots
would take too long before they started
crossing
even ordinary pedestrians were getting
confused
sometimes they couldn't figure out on
which side to pass the robots
because robots make a lot of small
adjustments to their direction
as they move this actually sparked a new
idea
what if we used movement to create a
universal language
like at intersections robots would
gently move forward before they start
crossing
to signal to drivers that it's their
turn
if they see someone in a wheelchair they
yield
by pointing themselves away from the
sidewalk to signal
that they're not gonna move some of you
may remember this
in 2015 canadian researchers sent a
robot
hitchhiking across the us it didn't get
very far
it turns out that robots can also use
some social skills
like if they're being tampered with
carnegie mellon researchers have
shown that small toy robots should play
dead
because people feel bad when they think
they broke it
but the living robots aren't toys
they're not small they're
out there in public we found that with
delivery robots
to get people to stop tampering robots
need to show awareness
it's kind of the opposite of playing
dead in this case
robots need to acknowledge the situation
to get people to step away
also word of advice if you're a robot
and you see small
kids run towards the closest adults
it turns out that some kids just love
harassing robots
so besides dystopia hollywood also
promised us some really cool robots
that would run our errands or keep us
company so far we've really focused on
food delivery
but in the future these robots can do
more
like they could gather excess food and
bring it to shelters every night
because in america we waste 30 percent
of our food
while 10 of our people experience food
insecurity
these robots could be part of the
solution or
when we have hundreds of robots running
around cities
we could have robots carry emergency
medications at all times
just in case someone nearby has an
allergic reaction or an asthma attack
these robots could be on site within a
minute or two
faster than anyone else and during
pandemics
robots can be a key part of our
infrastructure they can ensure
that we can provide our communities with
their essential needs
even during emergencies let me leave you
with one last thought
today objects can't get from a to b
without human help because our
three-dimensional world
is quite complex but new sensors and
ai can change that in a way
technology is like a baby that has just
learned to
recognize objects and understand words
and maybe even hold a basic conversation
but it hasn't learned to walk yet now
we are teaching technology how to
navigate the three-dimensional world
without our help we are entering this
new era
where in sentient objects are gonna get
up
and move freely and when they do
we gotta make sure they don't look like
aliens my vision for the future
is that when things come to life they do
so with joy
you know less like the movie terminator
and more like toy story thank you